[Música]
todos
y entonces al igual que en el cuento de
la bella durmiente' cuando venimos al
mundo no son concedidos talentos
por ejemplo
soy orgullosa hija de unos maravillosos
ingenieros que desarrollaron diseños de
máquinas y procesos de biorremediación
para el sector de los hidrocarburos
igualmente soy hermana de un brillante
maestro en bellas artes quien
recientemente dejó en alto el nombre de
nuestro país en sofía bulgaria
recibiendo el reconocimiento a una la
mejor obra de arte virtual recreando la
obra las bodas de caná de paolo veronese
mi hermano a partir del arte digital
entra en las obras y recrea escenas que
se pueden desarrollar dentro de ellas de
esta forma por ejemplo ustedes pues se
pueden encontrar ya hacia arriba a dos
personas que están intentando escaparse
esa última escena porque ya realmente
están aburridos
o aquí abajo pueden encontrar al
violinista y al chelista absolutamente
descontrolados pensando dónde quedaron
las partituras manos
de esta manera entonces mi hermano
vuelve a crear obras dentro de las obras
existentes generando arte
como ven me rodea el talento
lo lógico lo consecuente es preguntarse
y a ella qué talento le fue concedido
les quiero compartir que me hice la
misma pregunta durante muchos años
definitivamente por el lado de los
números no fue
yo creo que algún profesor realmente
ofendido en sus sentimientos cuando fui
su alumna vendió los derechos del examen
de geometría para hacer este m
yo sí encontré x
lo que pasa es que el profesor no
entendió
esa es la interpretación profunda del
hallazgo
pero ahí está
usted lo pueden ver
y pues de los mismos productores de el
sombrero del principito les presento mi
versión de un helicóptero
[Música]
yo supongo que es un reto para un
artista como mi hermano entrar en esta
obra y recrear que puede haber dentro
del helicóptero
quien es el ilustre personaje que lo
tripula
como ven
a mí me formas como con lo de la
asignación de los talentos y
algo nos salió bien ahí
así que mientras yo lograba encontrar
cuál era el don que se me había
concedido
pues me dediqué a cuidar los dones del
resto
y resolví convertirme en obstetra de
tecnologías es decir abogada en
propiedad intelectual y es allí donde
comienza esta historia
la aventura comienza en barranquilla
cuando la locomotora de la innovación
convoco a varios abogados de propiedad
intelectual de diferentes regiones del
país para que demostraremos una vez más
de lo que somos capaces
el reto subir el indicador de
patentabilidad a nivel nacional por
arriba del 1%
así que sin más armas que nuestros
propios conocimientos emprendimos la
batalla por lograr subir este indicador
a fin de lograr entrar a una agremiación
muy importante a nivel internacional a
la que colombia quería entrar
estando en esa búsqueda de tecnologías
patentables me encontré con uno de los
primeros bebés inventos
la esfera de rescate
este es un dispositivo del tamaño de una
canica
que fundamentalmente hace que sea
posible encontrar personas en situación
de inaccesibilidad en desastres en
momentos en los que hay escombros ruinas
o paisajes selváticos que hacen difícil
encontrar las personas tiene diferentes
mecanismos a partir de los cuales
lanzando las canicas es decir las
esferas dentro de la zona del desastre
donde llegan las esferas se puede
percibir cuántas personas son
sobrevivientes cuántas están vivas
cuántas están muertas y si algún
sobreviviente se topa con una de estas
bolitas pues puede interactuar con ella
y a través del dispositivo interactuar
con el exterior haciendo más fácil y
menos arriesgado para el recurso humano
que se encarga de salvar vidas acceder a
ellos y rescatarlos
jamás me voy a olvidar del primer
momento con esta tecnología
era la encargada de propiedad
intelectual de una universidad en la
costa
y allí llegó un joven investigador que
me dijo a mí dotto
le traigo una idea del tamaño de una
canica
en realidad
muy pocas personas creyeron en la
capacidad de este dispositivo me decían
que ni en matrix y tuve que apostar
incluso me cargo a que si era posible
recientemente antes de llegar acá la
patente de este dispositivo nos fue
concedida
y aventura continuó por santander allí
una persona de barrancabermeja
me permitió traer al mundo su tecnología
consistente en un dispositivo para
controlar las fugas de líquidos
comburentes en procesos de perforación
de pozos de petróleo básicamente este
dispositivo lo que hace es controlar ese
momento en el que se encuentra el
líquido tan valioso que está escondido
en la tierra y controla que eso no salga
disparado para todas partes y genere
riesgos de quemaduras en el personal que
se encuentra próximo al sitio de la
operación
el programa de brigadas de patentes
realmente aumentó de manera sensible los
indicadores de patentabilidad a nivel
nacional este programa buscaba encontrar
estas tecnologías que se podían proteger
mediante el mecanismo de patente donde
se buscó en las universidades con los
empresarios con los inventores en los
centros de investigación en los centros
de desarrollo tecnológico debajo de las
piedras si nos hubiera tocado
y logramos los siguientes resultados en
bogotá se lograron 412 patentes en
medellín 197 patentes en bucaramanga 81
patentes en cal y 73 patentes y en
barranquilla 54 patentes como pueden ver
el indicador superó la expectativa
esperada y colombia logró entre otras
por estos resultados ingresar a esta
agremiación internacional tan importante
mi aventura continúa en la universidad
que más patentes le ha generado al país
en el desempeño de la obstetricia
tecnológica en esta universidad se ha
logrado a través del programa de
propiedad intelectual duplicar el
volumen de patentes que se tenían
generando un importante progreso y
visibilidad para esta institución de
educación superior
y fue allí donde me encontré conmigo fue
allí donde me di cuenta que mi don
consistía en proteger proteger que
proteger el conocimiento de mi sangre su
capacidad creativa y entonces me
arriesgue y decidí incluso emprender y
me dedico a buscar talentos escondidos
para que compartan sus dones
descubrir en la propiedad intelectual mi
vocación y mi pasión en la vida me ha
permitido encontrar que la revolución de
mi sangre es la revolución del ingenio
circulan entre nosotros grandes
personajes que han desarrollado
soluciones científicas para problemas de
la raza humana
por ejemplo el 'cristo del colon de los
cerebros es colombiano y actualmente se
encuentra desarrollando fórmulas para
medicamentos del alzhéimer los cuales se
encuentra patentando
qué me dicen entonces del hombre que
repara corazones rotos el inventor del
marcapasos también es colombiano y
justamente esa tecnología a partir de la
cual logra que los corazones sigan
latiendo ha logrado escalar a la
nanotecnología
también podemos mencionar inventoras
porque es que también hay mujeres que se
han dedicado a solucionar problemas de
la vida humana nada más uno de mis
compañeros del tedh
tiene el tuyo el privilegio de conocerla
y ver cómo se dedica a solucionar
problemas de las personas que tienen
dificultades para comunicarse y han
podido ver ustedes los dispositivos que
desarrollan
y hay otra mujer que ha hecho que
júpiter esté más cerca
una investigadora que trabaja con el
organismo mundial dedicado a explorar el
espacio fue la encargada de llevar la
sonda que iba a acercar al hombre a ese
planeta por primera vez
saben algo
a mí me encantaría
inventarme si tuviera los conocimientos
técnicos una nueva versión de la esfera
de rescate
pero me encontré me encantaría
desarrollar una esfera que encuentre
talentos no personas en situación en
accesibilidad y entonces me encantaría
encontrar desarrolladores de
dispositivos
actores
y compositores de música
y desarrolladores de software
y jugarle un buen partido de canicas al
universo a ver qué pasa
a ver si se nos ocurre crear algo
protegible y de esta forma hacerle
honores a las palabras que dijo nuestro
nobel de literatura en el momento de
recibir su premio cuando manifestó que
las estirpes condenadas a cien años de
soledad encuentren por fin y para
siempre un segundo lugar una segunda
oportunidad sobre la faz de la tierra
muchas gracias
[Música]
vivo